14 heures tapantes pirlouit organise les
réjouissances de la journée on va
mélanger rugby et hand cet après midi
donc on aura un atelier avec louis sur
les poteaux là bas et puis incluant avec
sabrina
on sera sur un petit match de caen la
crise sanitaire a interdit toute
activité sportive en salle le club de
rugby du creusot a eu une idée invité
les autres disciplines à partager leur
grand terrain en plein air le but du jeu
c'est vraiment de mélanger un petit peu
tous les enfants parce que c'est vrai
que l'idée c'est que chaque enfant
puisse tirer profit un petit peu de ce
que chacun fait dans sa discipline
parmi les sportifs qui ont accepté
l'invitation de cet après midi les
handballeurs creusotin il initie les
jeunes joueurs de rugby aux règles de
leur sport je vais le répéter souvent on
n'a pas le droit de marcher avec la
balle après quelques exercices et un
petit match de hand et de rugby les
changes se révèle plus ou moins
fructueux c'est bien en plus on peut
marquer des buts je préfèrerais sordi
parce que c'est mieux
[Musique]
j'ai parents les parents présents en
revanche sont ravis de retrouver un peu
la vie d'avant la pandémie car il
retrouve un peu l'écho pas la joie
d'être dehors et de pouvoir jouer un peu
donc c'est très agréable pour eux si la
municipalité soutient activement
l'initiative elle ne baisse pas la garde
pour autant sur les gestes barrières on
a dû gel hydroalcoolique on lave les
ballons entre chaque catégorie d'enfants
pour pas non plus mélangé on prend
toutes les comment les mesures
nécessaires dont comprend les noms en
cas de problèmes comme ça si on les
donne à la récente à problèmes mais non
on auprès de clusters on n'a rien vu du
tout
les rugbymen compte poursuivre l
aventure avec d'autres clubs de la ville
pour défendre leurs valeurs communes
le sport